advice from chip hawkins founder of
electronic arts on finding your passion
as seen in zugo 101
i have probably the best personal
collection of games you're gonna find
anywhere
i've just been a nut for almost any form
of software but games especially whether
it's card games board games computer
games video games i've just got a
spectacular collection
and of course now i have four kids that
are different ages so when we want to
play boy we've got a fantastic set of
choices
you can't get anywhere with that
incredible passion because if you're an
entrepreneur there's going to be a lot
of bumps in the road
a great artist has to do their art
there's nothing that can stop them from
doing it
they just have to get it out there it's
the same thing for an entrepreneur if
you don't feel that way then you're
probably not really an entrepreneur
if you don't have a lot of passion for
it you're not gonna make it
and that's i think the big test
to learn more check out zuga 101 in the
link below
you